look out goats whoo cut it down who was  a little hairy got it down didn't get  killed in the process it's been a good  day so far that was a hard tree to get  down it was risky but it was a big tree  and a big tree like that has enough wood  in it for several days heating my cabin  cooking everything I need wood for all  right yeah look at that  got a nice 6-foot length that'll fit my  sled only problem is that's one heavy  load you got to go up this steep hill  right here on my way to camp it's gonna  be a big problem  but if I can get it to split I got some  wedges with me  then it'll be low enough in the sled it  won't topple over there's a crack right  here that naturally started through the  log maybe I get that to open up further  and split all the way through yeah start  one right here  yeah there goes one of these probably  enough to get through a whole day